good afternoon everybody
hi uh my name is alex gaynor i'm going
to talk about why ruby isn't slow
particularly why basically all about you
probably all the preconceptions you have
about
ruby's performance and dynamic language
performance in general
are really really wrong in this era so
five seconds of background i work at
rackspace
uh and i'm by and large a python
programmer there's actually almost no
ruby code in here
uh there's a lot of python code though
and i do a lot of open source stuff
you can ask me about that later so start
with what is the statement that you know
sort of i'm
making this indictment know that ruby is
slow and unfortunate this is
this is a thing we say a lot this is the
thing people say it's not a really
precise statement
and since i'm basically building this
talk on the premise of attacking its
validity
i want to unbox at least what i think
people mean when they make the statement
ruby is slow and of course almost
everything in this talk besides some
real specifics
applied to python it applies to
javascript it applies to lua
it applies to probably whatever your
favorite dynamic language is too
it's not real ruby specific it's about
the sort of set of dynamic languages we
basically wrote in the 90s and we wrote
while ignoring a whole bunch of research
about how to make these fast
so what we mean when we say ruby is slow
is
code written in ruby executes cpu bound
tasks
more slowly than other languages this is
sort of the precise version of that
except for it's missing details too
because
we are not talking about the fact that
when we say code written in ruby
executes we're not talking about how it
executes
we're implicitly thinking it runs on mri
or c ruby
or c python or whatever like that we're
not talking about
you know maybe it's different on
different cpus we are talking about cpu
bound as opposed to i o bound
and we're talking about irrelative to
other language there's no absolute
performance
of like this is how fast we think
computers should be we're saying it's
slower than we'd like to be where
what we'd like it to be is some other
language that is fast
and of course if you if you go to
someone and say why did you choose ruby
uh
you know it's so so slow you get a lot
of bad answers back and these answers
are not the bad answers this talk is
going to give
so common answers include our app is i o
bound we write web apps it's so cool you
don't have to care about cpu speed at
all
i got to tell you there's an amazing
correlation between people who will tell
you
oh my app is i o bound and apps that you
like trivially find 30
performance improvements in by changing
purely like cpu bound code it's
amazing the correlation you also get you
know we make it up with programmer
productivity
that might be a true thing i think
dynamic languages are super productive
things to write code in
that is in no way a response to you
execute cpu bonds
code slowly and finally in my opinion
the most depressing one
later when we actually needed to be fast
we'll rewrite in c
or scala or java or sml or some other
super
cool popular language that you know
really is fast it's a proper serious
language this one makes me sad because
i'm a compiler nerd
and we figured out how to make these
things fast and people seem
they seem hell-bent on abandoning you
know what i think are a set of really
good languages for writing stuff in
so ruby can be fast it is not
necessarily slow
and so to start with that i want to
break down even further what are the
myths about why we think it's slow
and this is like the 100 answer i get
from almost 100 people why is ruby slow
well the compiler doesn't know the type
so it's
so slow you know what does that mean uh
the you know there's you don't put types
in your program
you don't infer them it's not a type
inference language so
uh the compiler can't optimize why can't
it optimize it doesn't know the types
okay so what what is that what does that
actually mean what are the consequences
of not having types
what are the actual performance
consequences we think of not knowing the
types
so all function calls are indirect you
know if you got an assembly program you
tell them oh there's an indirect jump
they get like
they get really like freaked out like oh
you know that's that's gonna have bad
branch prediction it's gonna flush some
caches that's really uncool
uh we have that that is a wishful really
nice uh
idea in you know practical dynamic
languages in these interpreters
what this means you're probably going to
do a hash table lookup
you're doing this indirect function call
you know the way
the indirection is a hash table hash
table look us about 40 nanoseconds
good hash table on a modern x86 you know
recent intel cpu
40 nanoseconds sounds cheap unless
you're trying to do it on almost every
operation in your programming language
right 40 nanoseconds all the time
compared to
nothing is really really slow because
nothing is the cost in these other
languages for this stuff
uh all containers are objects so you
know you make an array of ins
in uh in c in a python
uh make you make an array of uh integers
making a list of integers what you get
is you get a nice uh
array of pointers to some that memory
that contains an integer and a bunch of
other stuff
so objects are way fatter and more
pointer directions that's expensive
uh instance variables attributes
whatever your language calls them
they're not at fixed memory offsets if
you ever look at like the assembler gcc
emits when you read a field out of a
struct
yet uh you get this uh mob with the
weird uh
addressing just read it and offset
python ruby it's like let's go find a
thing in a hash table
another 40 nanoseconds so
what if we were actually going to design
a fast ruby and i don't mean a language
that looks like ruby it's fast i'm
talking about a fast
vm a fast interpreter something that
really addresses these problems
looks at the architecture of how we
represent data uh looks at
you know making these things be as free
as we think they ought to be
so to address that we've got this tool
called our python our python's a
programming language
it is a statically typed type inference
programming language it's globally type
inferenced
you don't write types anywhere but
it compiles down to you know binary it's
a garbage collected language
uh it's got a nice fast modern
generational garbage collector pretty
cool
um the syntax is the same as python it's
it's actually uh basically a strict
subset of python code
and so why would we use this language
and the answer is
you probably should never use it our
python is a probably one of the worst
languages i've ever programmed in
it has bizarre semantics error messages
that are atrocious they're not long
they're they're real short they usually
all fit on a terminal
you can't understand them the errors
point to places nowhere near like
mistakes in the code are
the ui is atrocious you should never use
this if all you wanted was a type
inferenced
garbage collected language there's a lot
of good ones many of which have been
presented at this conference
probably you should just go use one of
those but our python's got one thing
nobody else has
it's got a just-in-time compiler
generator so in addition to being a
terrible language
it is a framework for writing high
performance dynamic languages on top of
it
so while many uh vms write their own
just in time compiler from scratch
meaning everything from looking at code
and figuring out how you want to type
specialize it to emitting assembly
you know something like v8 or lugit you
know where they write the full stack
if you use our python to build a
language to build a dynamic language
you don't have any of these steps all of
this stuff comes for free
and as part of that there are lots of
useful primitives that you want
when you're actually going to go
implement a dynamic language
lots of little tools that make it easier
and so it's built using a tracing jit
uh tracing just in time compiles have
been a thing for a while you've probably
heard of them because uh trace monkey
uh the original uh jit engine from
firefox
was a tracing just in time compiler
basically what that means is
tracing jit observes the execution of
your code
usually uh the unit it observes it
observes a loop
and it looks and figures out what code
paths are hot and then it compiles a
linear trace
so a linear sequence of instructions uh
that represent that with bail points so
any place you have an if
or there's an implicit if it basically
has what's called a guard
and what that means is we are not
handling this that that will be handled
elsewhere like just
jump out to the middle of nowhere and
ignore that when trying to consider the
optimization of these programs
let's look at an example this is a
function it's technically like
implements the collats conjecture i
don't know why that's significant it's a
thing it's a simple function fits on a
slide
there's probably a math person here
understands that uh
so this function's written in r python
uh looks a lot like python uh
and so these are real like machine
integers and let's say we were to
jit this so there's no dynamic type
checking there's actually no overhead we
wanted to remove
one look at what sequence operations we
observe so
first iteration through this what we're
going to observe is we you know we have
a loop so we have this loop and the
input variable to the loop is n
and so the first thing we do is check if
uh n is not equal to one
and uh it we get you know we get i zero
back
automatically numbered variables in this
uh representation
guard true so anytime you get to the
instruction afterwards the i
one equals i zero must be true if it was
false we would have like jumped out we
would have stopped running this code
there's fallback code that de-optimizes
and figures stuff out
then we and uh end with one we check if
that's equal to zero uh we guard that's
true and then we do division then we
jump back to the head of the loop
uh it's pretty simple there's not a lot
of like overhead we could have written
this function and compiled it in c
and like there was no overhead uh
because there's no dynamic language
there's no dynamicism we want to remove
from this but these are the concepts
this the whole guard concept is the
critical thing uh
to understanding tracing jits so the key
insight
to dynamic languages is that
there is all things that are almost
certainly true
but not certain uh and this is a thing
you can't really communicate to a c
compiler
in c you know a struct has these fields
it doesn't
almost always have these fields
a function either a reference to a
function either is or is not
constant it's either this is a totally
uh this is a totally uh
indirect jump or this is a direct jump
that you can like inline and call or
whatever
there's no this is almost always the
case
and that's that's the key bit that's why
traditional static compilers don't work
for dynamic languages
because you can't give them these maybes
these problems these almost definitely i
swear but not actually sometimes
so this is kind of what the ruby object
model looks like if you
simplify things and like remove all the
details and you have no inheritance and
you know you remove tons of details you
have class objects and they have
they have a hash table of methods you
can add methods to them and
add method can really be used to
redefine an existing method
you can find methods look them up by
name you have instances
instances have a class you can send
methods where
you find the method and you call it and
you can see there's a lot of details
missing like
you can't send the function uh you can't
send arguments
with uh your calls you don't have
inheritance you can't include modules
into classes there's tons of details
missing
but this is sort of the core of the ruby
object model and so this sucks
uh so particularly it sucks for
performance because when you uh when you
call send
you're gonna go find nothing buy methods
gonna do a dictionary look up the hash
table look up that's 40 nanoseconds we
just wasted
time spent not doing things you care
about your program doing time spent in
the vm doing bookkeeping basically
slow but uh we we know in practice 99 of
the time
if you call send with the same name to
the same class
you're going to be getting the same
method back so we want to find a way to
express this
to our computer we want to find a way to
express this to the machine
so our python gives us a couple
primitives that will hopefully let us
expose
the almost always logic so we talked
about guards
and uh now we look at you know what are
these tools that we have for writing
dynamic languages so
first one we have is called a light
ability which is kind of a weird word
it's not
really used anywhere else in computer
science literature that i've seen
basically on the lightable function the
rule is you must be able to
re replace the result of calling this
function with
an observe a previously observed result
so
if you know that all the arguments this
function are constant
replace it with the result uh this
property is also called referential
transparency
an important thing about a liability is
that you're allowed to align things like
caching
so if a function will also put something
in a cache you can still align it
so this is this is maybe where we try to
start right
so find methods alliable it's not quite
right though
what if you call the add method again
afterwards
then you have this previously observed
result it's no longer accurate you've
changed the result value it's
it's not true it's a light ability is
not a sufficient tool light ability is
sort of a static style tool like this
always
this is always something that's not uh
sufficient
for us uh so the next tool we have is
called uh promotion
and uh promotion ties in very closely
with guards promotion says
when you observe a result of this
generate a guard that the next time
it'll be true
so we've got this f function that
promotes its argument and then does uh
some serious computing
uh so we call we call f with uh 10
the uh code that will be omitted for
that promotion will be we will observe
that
uh 10 was passed so we we called promote
with 10 what that emits is
we that emits the code check if uh
x is equal to 10 uh because 10 was the
result we observed
so this is how we generate guards and of
course
in future code when you when you go to
execute that when you go to turn into
equal and guard true into machine code
uh everything afterwards i zero anytime
you see it
you'll be able to just replace with ten
because now we know it must be uh
it must be ten because we checked
basically guards
and promotion is used for when you have
something that's really cheap to check
for
but allows you to avoid really expensive
computation
so next thing we have is called quasi
immutability which is
by far my favorite term we have with the
possible exception of the black hole
interpreter
i won't talk about the black hole
interpreter we have lots of really cool
terms
uh quasi immutability is sort of super
cool uh
it's also super obscure i i just have to
like apologize on behalf of the syntax
a question mark i don't even know what
that is it
this was not a thing that was designed
clearly so
quasi-immutability is for expressing you
know the core of this concept
a field on an object which almost never
changes
so almost word again so our python
uh has a cool jit it does cool tricks so
basically when you read a field that's
marked as quasi-immutable what happens
is it will observe the fact that this
read occurred but it won't emit any code
so there's no
code emitted for quasi-immutable reads
and it just replaces that with the known
value but it keeps track of the
the fact that it made this assumption it
just reused a value without doing any
checks
but now whenever you write to this field
you'll have to just go blow away
all your old assembler just blow it away
it's now totally useless so this is for
you know sirius almost never changes
territory
so now we've got a couple primitives a
couple different uh pieces
couple tools we got to put them all
together and actually build a system no
one of these is enough to actually
implement a fast dynamic language so
here is now the optimized version uh no
joke all fits on one slide
this is all we need uh method lookups
are totally free
take uh know some basically no assembly
instructions
so what do we change we added that uh we
added this version field
starts at zero and it's uh it's
quasi-immutable
we added this indirection over find
method so now find method just calls
undefined method with with its version
and fi undefined method is now alignable
and send does promotion on its class
and a promotion on the name so what does
this mean what does this actually look
like
if we try to invoke this code so we've
got this really cool code
uh my object we send the method a method
to it
super cool code you probably write a lot
of it it's worth remembering that even
in ruby something like plus or minus is
a method sent just like this
so you're sending methods all over the
place imagine this being whatever method
you like
so we start getting inside a send and uh
first thing we use promote the class so
first thing we do is we read the field
class
sort of get feel does just reads a field
pretty intuitive
and this is like a c-struct style field
so get field is like one mob instruction
with an offset
and we check that uh we compare it
class is a pointer we compare it to some
observed my class
and guard crew so made a couple guards
uh we promote the name so now
uh you know a method was constant in our
uh
in our source code that's sort of
promoted we still promote it again
uh in case it hadn't already been a
constant from the source code
like if we done send with a variable
something like that
amid a guard again so now we inline into
find method and we add a few more things
so we read the version uh out of it we
would read the version of the class
which was p0 from before
and we call find method we don't inline
into it
we just make a call to it with the class
and with the version we just observed
this is the code we've got and of course
hidden inside this fine method
looks like we've got it you know it's
real pretty it's like seven instructions
it's actually it still sucks and all the
ways sucked before
as far as we can see because hidden
inside fine method
is uh this nasty dick look up this nasty
40 nanoseconds
so let's look at what happens so the
first thing that happens is we can
eliminate this
ptr equal on the string with this
observed constant string
it's always true that uh you know these
two constants are the same as each other
so that one goes away this becomes uh
guard true
true we can remove guards it's
constantly
provably uh true it can go away
just delete it so now we got this so
now we talked about the fact that any
time after you've guarded for something
you can just replace it with uh the
known value thereafter
so this gap field begins get field from
a constant
uh this version so because version is
quasi-immutable
now we can go ahead and just replace
that whole thing uh with some observed
value pretend it's 10
whatever uh so notice we also replaced
uh p0
with uh my class this constant again and
now we're calling find the method with
two constants find method is delightable
so all of its arguments are a lot are
constants uh
that means we can just replace it with
some observed result
and so now we're down to just three uh
three instructions actually
and each of these is basically a
one-to-one mapping with a cpu
instruction
so from these 25 lines of code
we've managed to reduce ourselves to no
hash table lookups
uh no 40 nanoseconds wasted three
instructions
and the cool property is if then we sent
another uh we
did another send on my object we'd be
able to totally reuse these
these would be true for any call site so
if we need
multiple back-to-back calls the second
one would have not even these three
instructions
and so the real result is a thing i
wrote called topaz
topaz is as perhaps you expecting
a ruby interpreter built on top of our
python
and it has this optimization and many
others it's not totally complete that is
you probably can't run your rails app
or your chef app since those are as far
as i can tell the two things people do
with ruby they're on
rails and chef so you can't run those
but you can run a lot of ruby in
particularly
in particular it runs uh thousands of
specs out of ruby spec
which is the unofficial official test
suite uh specification for ruby
runs uh quite a bit of that thousands of
specs worth
it has some other optimization so ruby
also has constants constants are cool in
that they are in no way constant and may
vary
it's naming is possibly literally an
impossible thing to do
so you can do this exact same
optimization right constants have the
exact same property that methods
have in that they're almost constant
almost always the same
so same sort of logic applies you can do
a similar thing with instance variables
using the same sort of primitives except
using a structure called a map
which is a thing that's been around
since about 1988 and which
neither c python nor c ruby nor
pearl nor basically anything besides
like v8 luagit pi
pi rubinius things like that implement
uh it's pretty impressive how much
research we can ignore
we also do type specialization so
instead of uh
doing the traditional dynamic language
thing which is put everything in a box
right
you put your integers in a box just uh
oh you one of those eight bytes yeah put
that on the heap in a box
we do type specialization when you type
specialized containers those are
type specialized containers aren't
actually like a super novel thing right
you just observe the fact that you keep
putting integers inside of an array
and uh then decide i'm just going to
store raw integers and have a fallback
mode
but uh the win you get is way better
with uh
excuse me an otherwise high performance
jet so all these optimizations exist in
a topaz
uh if you're interested there's a whole
bunch of links uh
so pipe.org our python is the
implementation language for pi pi
which is the hype which is the high
performance
uh just in time compiler for the python
language we have a bunch of benchmarks
at speed.pipe.org shows a geometric mean
of 6x improvement
over c python the source code for pi pi
and topaz is all open source
topaz website is online uh i imagine
there's going to be quite a few
questions about this so go ahead and hit
me
photo credit goes to brian curtin thank
you guys
so yeah uh question
sure so uh topaz versus mri the question
was uh are there benchmark results
yes i have some preliminary benchmark
results
uh i don't like to cite them because
they're mostly micro benchmarks but
they show about what you'd expect which
is anywhere from like
two 2x to about 500x depending on the
kind of code you're right this is
this is the sort of nature of dynamic
language speed ups and i think we've
entered a really cool
era there was an arrow where basically
the speed up you got
you could basically measure because you
were deleting this constant factor
overhead
interpretation overhead you know by
getting rid of the interpreter loop and
moving to some assembly
you got rid of a certain type of
overhead that was basically constant
throughout programs
and so you got improvements like
consistently 2x
we can't really cite numbers like that
anymore because now we're actually
getting closer to
you know how much overhead was there and
the overhead
uh from factors like boxing from factors
like these hash table lookups are
dependent on the code so if you do code
that does actual lookups in like a hash
object in a loop
we don't get much wins because those are
spending a lot of their time in the run
time
you know inside an actual hash table for
a thing that really is a hash table
but if you spend your code doing uh
numerix
that's wasting a lot of time in these
method lookups
that's where we get wins like 500x
so yeah any
no there's probably not a path uh for
any of the slanted mri
uh i i've never spoken to any of the mri
maintainers but
i can give you the conversation we have
with uh the c python maintainers on the
pi
side pretty regularly and basically the
conversation goes like
hey we've proved these great wins uh but
it means throwing away all your existing
code
and you know adapting to the new world
order
you know for a lot of good reasons uh
that doesn't want to happen
uh it's there's more complexity in the
system
so i think hopefully uh
go back a little hopefully this is uh
demonstrated the idea
that there's no need to become there's
no need to have complexity in the vm
itself
to express these ideas but there is
complexity to the system right
compared to the you know naive
interpreter loop everybody took like a
interpreter compilers course and cs
heard about
like there's complexity or emitting
assembler runtime it's not simple
so you know people like to see python or
mri maintainers
who are more interested in language
design questions uh
don't necessarily want to move
themselves to having a just-in-time
compiler and doing these optimizations
so what i think needs to happen is what
happened in the javascript world
where a bunch of vm implementers you
know
gave the world a gift and didn't give
people a choice about using it
uh so the reason there's a lack of
adoption
for systems like jruby and urbinius or
pi pi on the python side
is basically because they've abandoned
certain uh
you know albatrosses around our necks
what am i talking about
a whole bunch of giant piles of c code c
extensions basically
uh i know both jruby and mri have some
level of support for them
it will i imagine never be truly
complete
uh just like pie pies comp support for c
python c extension will never be true
truly complete and truly great we need
to
fundamentally java people got this right
like 15 years ago
when they convinced people to abandon
their c code and rewrite everything in
java
and you don't even have to totally
abandon your c code so pi pi is this
thing called cfi
it also runs on c python it's similar to
ruby's ffi library
it lets you load c code but not c code
written for mri c code written to be c
code
and so i think if we move our extensions
we move our dependencies away from these
things
and as users we we say you know these
the systems we're deploying on
we will move it'll eventually become a
world where these things are leading the
way well
rather than you know following and
implementing every change that happens
upstream
and once that happens i think the
language designers will follow
we got a dragon kicking and screaming i
think is the answer
do you have any plans in topaz or to
have like a programmer hint to the
interpreter what uh what it wants the
compiler to do
so instead of like having a jitted you
say i want
like this array to be an actual array
so it's a great question the question
was you know are there any plans to add
hints
you know for the end user programmer of
python or ruby to be able to give uh
you know basically tell the system hey
here's the thing i know
basically like we do with static
languages
and the answer is sort of so i
can't see a future ever where i think
there's a use for adding hints on local
variables
or things like that i think where we can
get wins
though are
possibly uh basically around a place i
think
java has basically failed which is a
lack of value types
specifically you can't do something like
say i have an array of these two pack
these array of two integers so structs
of two integers
as you would say and see in java you
know you end up with a pointer to an
object
you know takes twice as much memory as
the two integers
to store all that plus there's the
indirection hints to be able to say i
want arrays like that
i think are hugely valuable and if you
ignore the fact that sometimes you want
a pointer to a thing
cfi lets you do this by basically
letting you allocate random memory i
imagine
ffi in ruby does much the same i'm not
as familiar with its api though
but i think the idea of hints like that
and sort of really idiomatic libraries
uh you know for doing things like that
basically typing around data structures
is valuable i think
typing around code is not valuable at
least from perspective of
things the compiler needs
did you run into any pathological cases
so yeah so the question is are there any
pathological cases by which i think you
mean
like things in ruby that like outright
make it harder and possible to optimize
well that's it that's a great question
certainly my question is turns off
object space and group by default
because it's like so expensive
performance wise just to have it
available yeah so object space has this
uh
this thing called object space in uh
ruby it's cool thing it lets you iterate
like over every object
under the gc's control uh which
kind of sucks if you're targeting the
jvm because the jvm doesn't give you any
introspection
into the gc our python's gc do does give
you enough tools that you can actually
write that it's crazy slow
each object which is this method is like
a hundred times slower on topaz
but it works out of the box like you
don't need a custom flag you don't need
a custom flag to turn on
uh set trace funk for debugging or for
profiling
you don't need custom flags for any of
this there's no uh
pathological case i found that makes it
impossible to make something fast
so far uh probably the most interesting
thing i found to make fast
was uh exceptions and their back traces
specifically a ruby back trace is
different from a python back trace
in that a ruby back trace includes every
line number
as it was observed at the time uh you
make the uh
at the time the exception propagated all
the way up to the top frame
whereas the python back trace includes
all the steps
all the frames that the exception was
observed to have been raised through
so if you capture an exception object
and pass it around and it only raised
through two frames of your 40 frame call
stack
you'll only see two frames in the
traceback uh is backtrace
in contrast in ruby even if you only
raise the exception through two frames
it goes back all 40.
uh so the trick to observe is uh
basically if you look at the instruction
pointer
that the frame above you was at you can
basically record uh
a linked list of all these frames uh for
free
uh this is a trick other ruby
interpreters could take advantage of as
well
uh because right now i know raising an
exception is crazy expensive uh under
some of the ruby interpreters so
it's definitely a trick that could be
taken advantage of but no there's
nothing crazy impossible i found lots of
things that i would consider
pathological cases and ruby's behavior
that just shouldn't exist but
that's maybe a different question
okay uh probably the most pathological
thing i found is
there's a global variable and if you set
it all string comparisons become case
insensitive
that's the thing
and it's there because it was there in
pearl and 20 years and
yeah what do you feel like
because my understanding is that a lot
of the other uh
yep so this is the thing uh lots of uh
people implementing basically any
dynamic language [ __ ]
oh we're so fast uh it's not quite
complete yet but we swear we're so fast
and then they get more complete
and performance like tails off because
they were cutting corners
so that was this was a really explicit
design goal i had for topaz which was
i wasn't going to show anything until it
had the
corners cut so i spoke with charles
nutter who's one of the lead developers
of robinius
or sorry of jruby and uh you know he
actually did a blog post a couple months
ago
here's like the list of challenging
things in ruby and you know it's things
like you can redefine a method at any
point
it's that all integer arithmetic
promotes to a big integer on overflow
things like that and so i mean a
particular point is topaz is oddly
complete in some areas
in that it's got set trace function
promotion and overriding methods
randomly and evals and bindings and
stuff like that
while it's missing like methods on array
so i believe topaz is complete in all
the
important ways
uh can you do escape analysis yeah so
escape analysis is one of the most
important optimizations
the our python chip provides uh i can
walk
i probably can't walk through it in any
honesty without like background material
if you search there's a if you search
there's a really good paper
about escape analysis in pi pi which is
exactly the same and it has
good visualizations to make it easier to
understand than me talking would be
so you mentioned earlier that uh run
rails and shaft the two things
yeah out of the curiosity uh
is that are you ever planning on making
it so that they can
or is this a completely different
application no this is
it's missing methods on array and string
and random stuff like that
that you need to run rails so it's more
of a center hybrid problem
yeah i mean i consider the core classes
to be part of the language itself
um but yes it's
there there are parts of the language
that are missing uh
i can't think of what off top of my head
but little parts of the language that
are missing
but we can at least parse like almost
every single
ruby file now stuff like that it's it's
mostly the missing methods at this point
in libraries it's the standard library
have you dealt with encoding
no so encoding is one of the giant
completeness places that's
missing yeah and
people who are familiar with it are just
laughing in the background which is fair
yeah so uh stealing other people
borrowing whatever producing a
derivative work of other people's copies
of
of other people's copies of pure ruby
code is absolutely a thing so anything
that's pure ruby in
uh like mri just taking out right
uh some of the stuff that's pure ruby in
rubiness is a bit more of a challenge
because something that uses a special
primitives ruby rubinius exposes
into ruby and we don't expose those same
primitives so
some of that but yeah we actually write
a lot of the uh
stuff uh that we have in like pure ruby
so we have an array.uh each that's pure
ruby stuff like that
another one of the performance um
criticisms of ruby is the
lack of support for parallel computation
um is that a thing in topaz
so it's not a thing in topaz yet there's
not even like a no op thread that green
threads
uh basically i've been deferring because
one of the ongoing areas of research
work in pi pi
is software transactional memory support
uh so i'm waiting basically see what the
results of that research are before
making a decision about direction pi pi
right now is a global interpreter lock
in the same way mri or c python does
yes uh okay this is everyone thank you